Ah l'été! Les belles soirées chaudes à observer les étoiles.
Mais au fait,
c'est quoi vraiment une étoile ?
Dans une fameuse scène du Roi Lion,
Timon et Pumbaa avaient chacun une hypothèse.
- C'est quoi ?
- Des lucioles, Pumbaa.
Un genre de ver qui reste collé
sur cette espèce de machin bleu marine.
- Ahh ! Tiens !
Moi je pensais que c'était des bulles de gaz
qui brûlaient à des billions de kilomètres de nous.
- Toi à part le gaz, y a
pas grand-chose qui t'intéresse...
- Alors évidemment, vous vous dites certainement que c'est Pumbaa qui a raison. Une bulle de gaz qui brûle.
Et pourtant on va voir aujourd'hui pourquoi une étoile n'est pas franchement une bulle.
Pourquoi ça n'est pas vraiment
du gaz non plus
et surtout pourquoi ça ne brûle pas du tout.
La première chose à dire c'est que les étoiles
ne sont pas nées au moment du big bang.
Elles se sont formées progressivement.
Et pour comprendre
comment une étoile fonctionne,
c'est important de remonter à sa naissance.
Vous savez certainement qu'il existe plus d'une centaine d'éléments dans le tableau de mendeleïev.
Et pourtant au moment du big bang,
l'univers a vraiment fait les choses au minimum
puisqu'il n'a créé que de l'hydrogène
l'élément le plus simple: un proton un électron et un peu d'hélium.
Ces atomes qui ont été produits dans les premières minutes du Big Bang se retrouvent aujourd'hui.
accumulés en immenses nuages de gaz, comme ceux qu'on voit représentés sur ces belles images
Alors il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur comment ces nuages sont arrivés là. Et pourquoi certaines régions de l'univers en ont plus que d'autres.
Mais ce sera pour une prochaine vidéo. Ce qui est important pour notre sujet, c'est que ces nuages de gaz ont au départ une densité
ridiculement faible. Au mieux, quelques dizaines d'atomes par centimètre cube.
Mais comme la seule force à laquelle ils soient soumis c'est leur propre gravité,
eh bien, ces atomes s'attirent entre eux et le nuage commence à se contracter progressivement.
Alors c'est très très faible comme force. Donc ça prend des millions d'années. Mais bon à l'échelle de l'univers, c'est pas le temps qui manque.
Quand un nuage se contracte, sa densité augmente
et quand elle devient suffisamment importante
les atomes d'hydrogène
s'associent pour former
des molécules H2 : du dihydrogène.
On parle alors de nuages moléculaires.
Et ce sont dans ces nuages
que les étoiles vont pouvoir naître.
Des nuages qu'on appelle parfois
poétiquement des pouponnières d'étoiles
Si vous voulez en voir une belle, il y a la nébuleuse d'Orion située dans la constellation du même nom.
Alors elle est visible
plutôt en hiver.
Et même si vous ne la verrez
pas aussi bien que ça,
le spectacle est déjà très beau
avec une simple paire de jumelles.
Le point essentiel c'est que dans ces nuages,
au fur et à mesure de l'effondrement,
la pression
et la température augmentent.
Passé 3 000°C, les molécules
de dihydrogène se cassent en deux
puis entre 6 000 et 10 000°C,
les électrons et les protons, qui constituent les atomes d'hydrogène, commencent à se séparer.
On se retrouve alors
avec ce qu'on appelle un plasma.
Et donc techniquement ce n'est plus un gaz,
comme le prétendait Pumbaa, mais un plasma.
Qu'on appelle parfois le quatrième état de la matière.
En plus des trois classiques : solides, liquides et gaz.
Cette phase d'effondrement et d'échauffement
peut durer des centaines de milliers d'années.
Et à ce stade, on n'a pas
encore une étoile qui brille.
On parle de protoétoile.
Sauf qu'au bout d'un moment, et bien
la température au centre du nuage de plasma
devient vraiment élevée.
Et quand elle dépasse
10 millions de degrés,
l'étoile peut s'allumer.
Et on va voir ce que ça veut dire
vraiment que s'allumer.
Quand Pumbaa dit qu'une étoile brûle,
ce n'est pas vraiment correct.
Ce qui se passe dans une étoile ce n'est pas une combustion, qui serait une réaction chimique.
Mais il s'agit d'une fusion,
c'est à dire une réaction thermonucléaire.
Des atomes d'hydrogène
fusionnent
pour donner
des atomes d'hélium.
Cette réaction de fusion c'est celle
qu'on retrouve dans l'explosion des bombes H
et qu'on aimerait bien arriver
à contrôler dans une centrale
pour produire de l'énergie nucléaire
par fusion plutôt que par fission.
C'est notamment le but du projet ITER,
dont vous voyez ici une photo.
Mais comme certains le font remarquer malicieusement, on possède déjà une belle centrale à fusion nucléaire
disponible pas loin de chez nous.
C'est le soleil,
qui est une étoile évidemment
et donc brille grâce à la fusion.
Je l'ai dit: pour que la réaction de fusion s'enclenche,
il faut une température minimum
de 10 à 15 millions de degrés.
Alors ça peut paraître un peu bizarre
qu'il faille d'abord chauffer
pour ensuite
produire de la chaleur.
Mais pour le coup, ça marche comme
les réactions chimiques de combustion.
De même qu'il vous faut une allumette
pour démarrer un feu et bien, il faut
de la chaleur pour initier une fusion nucléaire.
C'est pour ça, d'ailleurs, que la fusion
de l'hydrogène en hélium ne peut se produire
que dans la zone
la plus chaude des étoiles qu'on
appelle le cœur ou le noyau.
C'est le centre de l'étoile et qui pour le soleil ne représente que 1% de son volume.
Bon, mais quand même
30 % de sa masse !
Cette réaction de fusion "hydrogène donne hélium",
je vous en parle comme si elle était simple.
Mais en fait elle n'est pas du tout.
Une première chose qu'il faut noter, c'est que le noyau de l'atome d'hydrogène c'est juste un proton.
Alors que celui de l'hélium c'est deux protons et deux neutrons.
Déjà ça fait quatre composants
mais surtout, d'où ils viennent les neutrons ?
Eh bien, ils viennent d'une capacité
qu'ont les protons de se transformer en neutrons.
Alors voici le schéma complet
de la réaction de fusion.
D'abord deux noyaux d'hydrogène
donc deux protons fusionnent.
Puis, l'un des protons se transforme en neutrons,
grâce à ce qu'on appelle une désintégration bêta
et en émettant un positron et un neutrino.
On obtient alors du deutérium,
qui est de l'hydrogène avec un neutron en plus.
Alors petit aparté sur les trucs qui ont été émis au passage.
Le positron et le neutrino.
Le positron c'est un anti-électrons.
C'est de l'anti-matière.
Et il va aller se désintégrer avec le premier électron qui lui passe sous la main, en produisant du rayonnement donc de la chaleur.
Quant au neutrino, vous savez peut-être que c'est une particule qui a la spécificité
de ne presque pas intéragir
avec le reste de la matière.
Et donc, il va s'échapper du soleil et partir à la conquête du système solaire.
Et à l'heure où vous m'écoutez, ce sont environ 5000 milliards de neutrinos qui traversent votre corps, à chaque seconde, en provenance directe du soleil.
Mais revenons
à notre réaction de fusion.
On a produit du deutérium donc. Ce deutérium absorbe à nouveau un proton et devient de l'hélium 3 avec un seul neutron.
et quand deux hélium 3 produits
de cette façon se rencontrent,
ils peuvent fusionner pour donner un hélium 4: la forme de l'hélium la plus courante, qui contient deux neutrons.
Et tout ça en rejetant au passage, deux protons.
Alors vous voyez que le processus de fusion de l'hydrogène en hélium est quand même assez compliqué.
On appelle ça la chaîne de réactions proton-proton.
Et quand je dis que la réaction est compliquée, ce n'est pas seulement qu'il y a beaucoup d'étapes.
Mais que les réactions ne se produisent pas facilement.
Alors certes, au centre d'une étoile, on a plein de protons qui se tapent les uns avec les autres à 15 millions de degrés.
Et pourtant la fusion reste un phénomène assez rare et donc la réaction n'est pas très efficace.
Sur ce sujet, je vous recommande la vidéo de l'excellente chaîne "J'm'énerve pas, j'explique"
qui nous montre à quel point certaines étapes de la chaîne proton-proton sont compliquées et comment tout ça finit par
fonctionner uniquement
grâce à une chose: l'effet tunnel.
Une petite illustration du fait que la réaction de fusion n'est pas très efficace.
Regardez cette courbe. Elle vous montre la puissance dégagée par un mètre cube de soleil en fonction de la position par rapport au centre.
Dans les couches extérieures c'est zéro.
Je vous ai dit : tout se passe dans le noyau.
Cette courbe nous dit que même si vous préleviez un mètre cube de plasma dans le noyau, pour le mettre, mettons, dans votre salon.
Eh bien, il vous fournirait une énergie que de quelques dizaines à quelques centaines de watts en moyenne.
Beaucoup moins efficace
qu'une cheminée ou un radiateur.
Et heureusement d'ailleurs, parce que si la fusion dans les étoiles était plus efficace,
elles auraient épuisé tout leur hydrogène en quelques millions d'années seulement. Et on serait pas là pour en parler.
Je vous ai expliqué tout à l'heure, que les réactions de fusion nucléaire ne se produisaient que dans le coeur de l'étoile.
Là où il fait suffisamment chaud.
On peut se demander pourquoi, à force de s'effondrer, toute l'étoile n'atteint pas la température suffisante pour que la fusion se produise partout.
Et bien la raison c'est que quand l'étoile démarre sa fusion, l'effondrement fini par s'arrêter.
Au sein d'une étoile qui brille, il règne une forme d'équilibre. D'un côté la gravité pousse l'étoile à s'effondrer sur elle-même
comme le faisait le nuage de gaz
qui lui a donné naissance.
Et de l'autre, comme les zones au centre sont plus chaudes, la pression y est plus importante et va contrebalancer la force de gravité.
Il existe plusieurs équations qui décrivent les phénomènes qui se produisent dans une étoile.
Et qui permettent de comprendre
cet équilibre.
alors je vais pas vous les détailler mais sachez qu'elles permettent de calculer par exemple la densité,
la température, la pression ou encore la luminosité en fonction de la distance au centre de l'étoile
voici une représentation de ces quantités pour le cas du soleil et il y a quelques points intéressants qu'on peut noter
Bon la masse volumique tout d'abord augmente au fur et à mesure qu'on s'approche du centre, assez logique
en plein coeur, elle atteint 160 tonnes
par mètre cube
ce qui est beaucoup mais pas non plus démentiel hein. Seulement huit fois plus que le métal le plus dense qu'on connaisse: l'osmium
la température, elle, varie environs de 16 millions de degrés au centre, jusqu'à seulement
5500°C à la surface
quant à la puissance cumulée dégagée, qu'on appelle la luminosité, elle est de près de 400 millions de milliards de giga watts
alors par comparaison une centrale électrique aujourd'hui c'est maxi quelques giga watts
une chose intéressante que l'on peut déduire en manipulant les équations qui décrivent le fonctionnement d'une étoile
c'est que la température et la luminosité de l'étoile sont toujours liées entre elles et ne dépendent que d'une chose: la masse de l'étoile
vous voyez ici un petit diagramme dans lequel on peut représenter pour chaque étoile sa température de surface
en abscisses et sa luminosité en ordonnée. Alors notez deux choses: pour des raisons historiques
on représente l'échelle des températures à l'envers. Les plus élevées sont à gauche et les échelles sur les deux axes sont logarithmique
si je place le soleil, il se trouve ici
maintenant imaginez une étoile
disons 50 % plus massive que le soleil
on peut calculer sa température et la luminosité grâce aux équations et elle se retrouverait ici
à trois fois la masse du soleil ce serait là et puis 6, 10 ou 30 fois plus dans ce coin-là
plus une étoile est massive plus sa luminosité et sa température sont importantes
inversement si je prends des étoiles moins massives que le soleil, eh bien elles seront de moins en moins lumineuses et de moins en moins
chaudes en surface. Ce que je vous ai tracé là, ce sont des résultats de calculs, obtenus avec des équations
mais ce sont aussi des choses qu'on peut mesurer en observant des vraies étoiles
la luminosité d'une étoile peut se déduire en mesurant sa brillance, ce qu'on appelle la magnitude et en connaissant sa distance à nous
pour la température de surface c'est plus subtil, elle est reliée à sa couleur
plus une étoile est bleue, plus elle est chaude. Tandis que plus elle est rouge, plus elle est froide
en observant la couleur d'une étoile on peut estimer sa température de surface
alors notez quand même une chose: contrairement au lien qu'on fait dans le langage de tous les jours
pour une étoile, le bleu est une couleur chaude et le rouge une couleur froide
et donc si on place tout un tas d'étoiles connues dans le diagramme luminosité-température, voici ce qu'on obtient
ce graphique, on l'appelle le diagramme H-R pour Hertzsprung-Russell, qui l'ont chacun imaginé indépendamment au début du 20e siècle
prenons quelques étoiles connues. Allez Altaïr dans la constellation de l'Aigle, qu'en été vous pouvez voir à peu près au dessus de vos têtes
eh bien elle est ici dans le diagramme
Spica dans la constellation de la Vierge, visible vers l'ouest en début de soirée, se trouve là
quant à Proxima du Centaure, vous savez l'étoile la plus proche de nous et autour de laquelle on a découvert une exoplanète en 2016
eh bien elle se trouve ici. C'est ce qu'on appelle une naine rouge
sa température en surface n'est que de 3000°C. Sa masse, un dixième de celle du soleil et sa luminosité, 10.000 fois plus faible
pas du tout le même genre d'étoiles que le soleil donc
alors tout ça est très bien. On a un bel accord entre les équations qui nous permettent de calculer la luminosité et la température de surface
d'une étoile et ce qu'on peut en observer
des grosses étoiles bleues, des petites étoiles rouges et des étoiles intermédiaire blanches ou jaunes
et pourtant, il faut quand même que je vous avoue une chose. Je vous cache une partie de la vérité
il existe dans le ciel d'autres étoiles
qui ne collent pas dans ce schéma
Vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler des étoiles qu'on appelle les géantes rouges ou bien les naines blanches
elles se situent ici et là dans le diagramme.
Pas du tout au même endroit que les autres
toutes les étoiles dont on a parlé avant, que l'on trouve dans la diagonale du milieu, on dit qu'elles sont dans la "séquence principale"
et cette séquence principale, c'est uniquement pour les étoiles disons à "l'âge adulte"
quand les étoiles commencent à vieillir, d'autres phénomènes que ce dont j'ai parlé, commencent à se dérouler à l'intérieur
et c'est ça qui va provoquer des changements
à partir du moment où elle s'est allumée, une étoile fusionnent l'hydrogène situé dans son coeur
mais de fait, il y en a
de moins en moins de disponible
et quand tout son coeur s'est transformé en hélium, eh bien la fusion s'arrête
sauf que je vous avais dit qu'une étoile obéit à un équilibre
l'énergie dégagée par la fusion permet de contrebalancer l'effondrement gravitationnel
est donc quand il n'y a plus d'hydrogène disponible dans le noyau, eh bien l'effondrement en reprend
le temps que l'étoile met à épuiser tout l'hydrogène de son cœur dépend de sa masse initiale
sauf que
plus une étoile est massive
plus la réaction de fusion est
rapide et donc il se passe un truc contre intuitif.
Ce sont les étoiles les plus grosses qui vivent le moins longtemps
ce diagramme représente ce temps approximatif qu'une étoile passe dans la séquence principale, en fonction de sa masse. C'est une échelle logarithmique toujours
pour une étoile comme le soleil,
cela dure environ dix milliards d'années
alors vu que le soleil n'est âgé que de 4,5 milliards d'années, il n'en est en gros qu'à la moitié de sa vie d'adulte
donc on a le temps. Mais une étoile ayant 40 fois la masse du soleil ne passera que quelques millions d'années dans la séquence principale
avant de commencer
sa phase de vieillissement
pour les étoiles plus légères c'est tout le contraire, à tel point qu'une étoile comme Proxima du Centaure
une naine rouge presque dix fois moins massive que le soleil
pourrait très bien rester là encore mille milliards d'années. Soit 70 fois l'âge actuel de l'univers
on voit que pour les étoiles la durée de vie n'est vraiment pas la même pour tout le monde
et le destin non plus d'ailleurs. Alors voyons un peu ce qui se passe. On l'a dit: une fois l'hydrogène du cœur épuisé
l'étoile reprend sa contraction et la température à l'intérieur augmente à nouveau
à tel point que l'hydrogène des couches autour du noyau fini par atteindre le seuil suffisant pour fusionner à son tour
et du fait de l'augmentation de pression, les couches encore plus extérieures se retrouvent repoussées
donc vu de loin, l'étoile enfle, devient très grosse mais sa température de surface elle diminue
grosses étoiles mais plus froide en surface eh bien voici où elle se retrouve dans le diagramme H-R
c'est ce qu'on appelle une géante rouge
des étoiles de ce type il y en a plusieurs dans le ciel par exemple Aldebaran dans la constellation du Taureau
une fois arrivé à ce stade, ça devient compliqué. Car l'évolution d'une étoile va pouvoir suivre plusieurs chemins, notamment suivant sa masse
on sait que quand la température du coeur devient encore plus élevée, proche du milliard de degrés
l'hélium qui s'y était accumulé va à son tour se mettre à fusionner pour produire du carbone
l'énergie ainsi libéré permet de redonner en quelque sorte une seconde jeunesse à l'étoile et dans certains cas le carbone peut à son tour
fusionner en oxygène. Pour les étoiles plus massive, on peut même avoir production d'éléments plus lourd du tableau périodique
comme le néon le sodium magnésium etc
dans le cas du soleil
on pense qu'il finira par expulser la majorité de ces couches extérieures pour ne laisser qu'un tout petit noyau chaud et brillant
dans lequel la fusion aura cessé: ce qu'on appelle une naine blanche
si on visualise ces changements dans le diagramme H-R, le soleil passera donc de là, à là, puis à là
Alors il y aurait encore beaucoup à dire sur les destins des étoiles, parce que suivant les circonstances
certaines deviendront des étoiles à neutrons, des trous noirs ou exploseront en supernova. Mais ça nous amènerait un peu loin
si tout cela vous intéresse, je vous recommande la chaîne "Le Sense Of Wonder"
qui a notamment traité
de la mort du soleil et des supernova
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce que j'ai raconté je donne plein de petits détails dans le billet
de blog qui accompagne la vidéo comme d'habitude et comme toujours likez et partagez, la cloche, tout ça
facebook et twitter c'est pour les actus de la chaîne et on se retrouve très vite pour des nouvelles vidéos. A bientôt.